that talks about the power of indicators
in fact it uses GDP to make that point
saying that without measures of economic
aggregates like GDP policymakers would
be adrift in a sea of unorganized data
which kind of for those who are familiar
with the space describes the
biodiversity world today it's a sea of
unorganized data and you when I talk
you'll see a bit about what I mean and
they go on to say that GDP and related
data are like beacons that help
policymakers steer the economy towards
the key economic objectives okay so it's
a debate as to whether GDP is a good
indicator to identify the best policy
objectives for the betterment of society
that's a separate point but the point
they're making is that you need this if
you don't then you've got policymakers
in adrift in a sea so there's quite a
few indicators which are considered
relevant for the world of ecosystems and
biodiversity how do you make sense out
of these well broadly speaking there are
three ways of classifying all these
indicators so one way is to look at
which space which space of of human
wellbeing are the impacting is it more
in the economic side more on the social
side or more on the environmental side
and of course you there's a kind of Venn
diagram which you can draw which covers
covers these and if you look at the sort
of cross between economic and
environmental spaces there's of course
not very much unless you go into the
green GDP and genuine saving space HDI
is sort of kind of touching upon the
crossover point between all three but
not really it's mainly between social
and an economic and then you've got
various indicators which are purely
social indicators you got Green GDP and
inclusive wealth which includes a wealth
is sort of in the center space Green GDP
is is more in the space between economic
and environmental wealth and and then
you've got this whole armoury of
indicators which is available for
measuring ecological and environmental
factors including the CBD indicators the
SEBI indicators of the European Union
the Red List indices the footprint and
so on and so forth a second way of
cutting the same population of
indicators is to not say like which area
of well-being are they addressing are
they measuring but rather
what are they like I mean what kind of
indicators are they are they single
indicators I mean do they measure
something like co2 are they basket
indicators they composite indices are
they national income account related so
that's another way of classifying them
rather in the manner in which they
measure or what they measure is against
the area which they their measurement
can impact and yet a third way is to
look at this whole idea of drivers and
pressures in other words are they
helpful in measuring the state of
ecosystems in biodiversity are they more
helpful in identifying what are the
pressure points and what are the drivers
of loss of biodiversity or are they
actually measures of policy response
what's being done about it and therefore
what is the impact of what's been done
about it so you can classify it in that
sense as well and then see whether they
are more about pressures or drivers
whether they're more about responses or
the state of biodiversity and the
reality is in fact that the whole space
is complex because you have to see what
indicators are used for and that's
perhaps the most important question to
ask like who uses these and why what are
they used for
so you'll find for instance red list
being used a lot in the scientific
community in terms of identifying
extinction approaching species and so on
Sebby indicators i use a lot in managing
especially in the european union not
surprising and your whole host of
indicators like the footprint and the
human development which are there in the
space of public discussion but also
being used in in terms of goal setting
and policy making and then finally
there's a lot which goes into just pure
analytics and good research paper so
there are there are actually different
users different users and different
users for these indicators as well the
overall numbers are worth measuring at
two levels once again you need to
recognize that the adjusted GDP is a
result of original GDP plus the incomes
that you've not accounted for minus the
depreciation that you've not accounted
for
sometimes one compensates the other
exactly sometimes it's higher sometimes
it's lower so if you want to get to the
truth you need to know both the changes
in flows that you are not accounted for
and the the depreciation in stock that
you're not accounting for and that's why
it's important then you can see these in
the two different colors of yellow and
the fact is that if you look at capita
losses we are talking about stock
adjustments in across the whole of the
country at minus nine percent of annual
GDP that's one hell of a big number nine
percent of India's GDP were talking
about hundreds of billion 100 billion
plus dollars that even at that time
that's a huge amount of stock loss to
take place during this accounting period
2000 to 2003 and of course compensating
there there is some income as well so
it's not it's not just one-sided but the
fact is the floor adjustments are small
compared to the stock adjustments
you